I am not the biggest fan of starget
universe but I'm going to argue that we
desperately need a conclusion of SGU if
we're going to restart the Stargate
franchise welcome to CRA your SciFi TV
and moveie channel I am hopeful that in
2024 we're going to get a return of
Stargate command that we're going to be
getting a new Stargate series and a
movie probably a movie but how does
Amazon start this franchise is it really
as easy as some people think well I have
to argue that no it's not going to be a
continuation after More Than A decade is
not a massively easy Prospect
particularly not for something like
Stargate now you could argue Quantum
Leap did it recently and they did it
very well but that was a completely
different kettle of fish it was a far
more focused far smaller universe that
they were exploring it was very simple
to just have somebody new go into a new
Quantum accelerator Stargate is
different imagine for a second that the
whole show was real imagine the
technological advancement over 10 years
of Stargate sg1 we went from running
through the Stargate that we could
barely operate with machine guns and
getting that asses handed to us every
week to by the end of that decade having
warships that were pretty much the
baddest thing in the universe with
weapons that could cut through gow
Shields like they weren't there we went
from knowing nothing about the universe
to becoming the Slayer of gods by the
end of it now another 12 years has gone
by so how do you restart that franchise
what tone do you set how do you explain
what's happened in the last decade there
are massive decisions that need to be
made for example will the Stargate be
known to the public now because that
changes what Stargate is
dramatically all of these things have to
be done so why am I bringing this into
Stargate Universe well it seems to me
that a nice way of restarting the
franchise is to complete what was
started all those years ago finish off
the circle do some something that saves
the crew of the destiny and through that
explain an awful lot of what's gone on
in the last 12 years let me explain so
if you had a mission at Stargate command
and the plan was to go and save the
destiny crew you could have an awful lot
of stuff sort of in the background that
explains what's happened in the last few
years so that we can infer a lot of the
history without them actually having to
blatantly tell us
so for example if the public do now know
about the Stargate there are lots of
ways that you could visualize that
without actually having to point it out
as it were you know you could have the
Stargate command is no longer military
you can show the gate in the middle of a
city or something like that we could get
to see a lot of the Starships for
example that we now have so are we on a
bc35 bc36 these are the sort of things
that fans desperately want to know
because again that could be part of the
mission we could learn what's going on
in the universe as a whole are there any
new villains knocking around that could
also be brought into this mission to go
and save SGU maybe there's a reason why
we have to go and save the crew of the
Destiny or why we have to go to the
destiny to solve a problem we're now
facing in the universe again a nice easy
way to introduce a lot of this stuff
without actually having to sort of bang
on about it I like the idea actually
that we at the SGC have to go to the
Destiny for some reason that's going to
tie into the reason why the franchise is
coming back now we could have a
storyline where actually the universe
has been quite quiet for the last 12
years we've had to deal with the Lucian
Alliance really but nothing else there's
not been a big go World Uprising or a
new threat like the Ori or anything like
that but some new threat has emerged and
it's something to do with the Ancients
and that there is something on the
destiny that will help us resolve that
or understand this new threat you know
what I'm going to say now I'm going to
say the furlings I'm sorry but I just
think that would be the perfect villain
for the new Stargate series and I it' be
a really cool twist this peaceloving
race has come back and now for some
reason they're a problem let's do that
that's going to cause comments get into
the comments and tell me whether you
think that's a good idea or not and then
read the previous comments and I bet you
within five or six comments you will
read somebody say evil Ewoks it's bound
to happen and I love every single one of
you that write that comment because that
means you've been watching our lives if
you're enjoying the video don't forget
to like subscribe and hit that Bell
notification so you miss none of our new
videos and most importantly leave a
comment it's a community after all we
want to know what you think too so what
are the chances the new Stargate
franchise could return with a conclusion
to SGU well we've heard several rumors
um going back over a year now that
actually Robert carile was being
approached by Amazon and MGM to do
something now we then heard rumors that
there was going to be a Stargate SGU
animated movie now I've since heard that
that actually isn't true or at very
least somebody mgm's told me it's not
true they actually told me they laughed
when they saw that video about it and I
suspect it's not true
but talking to a couple of people I am
being told that actually this was a very
early idea that when there were talks
about doing Stargate in cooperation with
Warner Brothers and this was back when
apparently Bad Robot were involved in
this discussion as well sorry Bad Robot
and Stargate just makes my blood run
cold that actually there was an idea for
an animated movie that this would be
done very much sort of think about the
Babylon 5 the road home animated movie
recently that it would look very much
like that and that Robert carile was
approached about the possibility of
doing that now there would have been
lots of reasons why actually this
wouldn't have been a terrible idea for
one Warner Brothers have the setup to do
it they could have done it quite
inexpensively and they could have done
it very quickly again look at what they
did with Babylon 5 they were able to
keep it really secret nobody knew it was
happening and then they released it
really quickly they released it on
Blu-ray in 4k and these nice little box
sets it made really good money and then
they released it on on the streaming
again made good money they have a
business model that would have worked
for this and Stargate fans would have
gone nuts would have all bought it even
if you weren't big SGU fans it would
have also made sense in that a lot of
the actors went into cryo so in theory
they haven't aged at all in the last 12
years but Eli would have done so it
would have created some interesting
continuity issues continuity issues that
would have been very easy to get around
by animating the project the fact that
Eli is now skinny basically would have
just been very easily explained by the
fact he's been starving for years but
the fact that Rush tord Etc hadn't aged
that would have been a little bit more
difficult to explain they might have
also though struggled to get a few of
those actors to return mnar Wen is quite
busy with other projects but they
probably could have at least got her to
come and voice something for the
animated movie so again there are
reasons why practically this probably
wasn't a terrible idea and in lots of
ways I'm a little disappointed it's not
happening I am hearing though that we
are going to get some comic book
releases before the big movie event
think about like what Star Trek I've
done recently that just before a new
series of card Etc there's a short comic
book run something that builds up
towards the new story and explain some
of the background for it I'm being told
we're going to get to see exactly the
same thing again with
and possibly a couple of books as well
that'll explain a few things so again
maybe we'll get SGU concluded in comic
book form I think that would be a
massive shame but at least we would find
out what's happened unlike the comic
books we've already had about Stargate
and the conclusion to SGU comic books
that if I'm honest didn't make any sense
and we need to pretend didn't happen but
the one last reason why I actually do
believe we will get in SGU conclusion is
something I told you about over a year
ago now that Mark Fergus has already
talked about SGU to MGM and Amazon so I
talked to you about a development
meeting that happened in the late 2022
Mark Fergus one of the guys that
developed the expanse and the person
that we still strongly believe is going
to be heavily influencing the return of
Stargate was talking to Executives and
they were just bouncing ideas around
about how they would return with the
franchise he was talking about the
planet Builders which was a major part
of the second season of star Universe
the planet Builders were at the end of
the day probably the most advanced
species we ever got to see assuming they
weren't imagined which is actually a
slight possibility but assuming they're
not imagined and they were real Mark
Fergus seemed to be very enthusiastic
about developing that story further now
again if we have a conclusion of SGU we
could bring that into it as well Not
only would we get to maybe find out what
the mission of the Destiny was and maybe
how the planet Builders tied into that
but that could then all be brought back
into explaining or understanding the new
threat back home I can see a very simple
way to tie all this together and whoever
ends up doing this really does have a
really really nice opportunity to
actually do it in a clever way that
makes us all very happy but also gives
them a foundation for a new Stargate
franchise because however they decide to
do this whatever tone they decide to go
with however they decide this show will
feel is going to affect the franchise
for a decade if assuming it's successful
that is really really important we need
a Stargate show that still feels like
Stargate and one really easy way to do
that is to tie it into Stargate Universe
and maybe also Stargate Atlantis because
let's be honest as well the Stargate
Atlantis series needs a conclusion too
so is this a likely plan for Amazon and
MGM I'd say so I think it's very likely
there some variation of what I'm talking
about is how they will do this and that
actually we're going to get to see the
destiny once again because it just makes
sense now I am also going to say very
quickly that just because something
makes sense doesn't mean movie and TV
creators will do it because a lot of the
time new creators come in and they want
to do something new this is one of the
reasons why I'm really really desperate
for Mark Fergus to still be involved in
this or maybe let's hope they get Brad
Wright involved because at least then
they will respect what came before
because even though Mark Fergus is a new
voice in the Stargate franchise
everything I hear about him suggests he
is a massive fan and that he would
actually like to do something that does
respect what came before and if Studios
haven't learned that Lesson by now that
if you are going to bring back a
franchise that if you do not respect
what came before it will fail then these
Studios don't deserve to be allowed to
make these TV
shows it really is a simple lesson
respect the show that we love if you're
going to bring it back it's not
complicated
but guys get into the comments and tell
me what you think does it make sense for
SGU to be a part of the beginning
because it would explain the
ending but guys get into the comments
tell me what you think does it make
sense to bring SGU back and to bring
back the destiny not just to conclude
what happened before but as a really as
a springboard for what is going to come
I actually think
and if it does what way would you do it
how would you bring in the destiny to
make sense of what's come
before how would you bring in the
destiny to help make sense of a
new and guys get into the and tell me
how would you do it if you were going to
go and save
the and tell me how would you do it if
you were going to go and save the crew
of the Destiny save Eli what would you
do and how would you tie it into the new
project would you at all or would you
just go and save the destiny and have
that as a standalone Min serious say get
to the comments and tell me exactly what
you think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also go to patreon.com citre where most
of our new videos premere first and you
get to see them without the adverts you
lucky bunnies finally go and check out
c.co which is our dedicated website and
we do articles based on most of our
videos and we try to add a little bit
more information for you to
digest as always please stay safe and
see you next time I think it is actually
very likely that some variation of what
I'm being
taught I think it's very likely that
some variation of what I'm being taught
one and be
what